la guest moussavi merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors pour
commencer quelle est la situation
sanitaire aujourd'hui dans le pays
merci de m'avoir communiqué et je peux
vous dire que la situation sanitaire est
très disponible
surtout après c'est l'histoire d'un
embargo imposé par les états unis
parce que moi je suis généraliste et je
suis diabète ou non en ce qui concerne
le corps en un virus je ne peux pas
beaucoup parlé de cette situation parce
que nous aussi nous nous sommes enfin
vous sont au courant des statistiques
données par le gouvernement et par le
ministère de la santé
mais ce qui est important au niveau des
médicaments et au niveau de beaucoup de
beaucoup dessus du sourcil qui sont
nécessaires dans notre métier il y à un
énormément mais ce n'est pas dû aux
exports ou au rapport aux sanctions mais
c'est surtout en fonction au niveau des
déplacements de l'argent et financiers
qui sont imposés par hésitation
alors l'europe a envoyé une aide en iran
la france notamment
comment est ce que l a été perçue
c'était des est-ce que vous en avez vu
les effets très concrètement
personnellement parce que je quand je
vous ai dit je suis en premier lieu et
je ne visite peu les patients
diabétiques
et à ce niveau je ne veux pas m'exprimer
vraiment que si on a vraiment perçu les
effets des aides de la france
mais en ce qui concerne le manque de
médicaments
ça se sent énormément et c'est très très
difficile pour les passions
quel est l'état d'esprit de la
population des patients que vous croisez
la journée
il faut dire que des trains est très
très négatif surtout au niveau de manque
des différents types de stylos
d'insuline
nous avons énormément de manque et
surtout au niveau de certains types de
stylos d'insuline qui ne se trouvent
plus et qui n'existe plus sur le march
est ce que vous avez vu un effet du
confinement qui a eu lieu sur place en
iran pas vraiment non parce que vous
savez le confinement n'est pas n'est pas
imposée aux iraniens ça n'a jamais été
comme ça c'est à dire que on ne vous
oblige pas de rester à la maison
on ne vous oblige pas de ne pas aller
travailler c'est vrai que certains
commerces sont fermés et obligatoirement
sont fermés mais il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de gens qui ne qui ne prennent pas au
sérieux cet esprit de confinement et
donc qui sort et qui font le marché par
exemple sur les marchés de produits
alimentaires frais vous voyez énormément
de gens qui viennent faire leurs courses
et qui ne font pas forcément protéger ni
par les masques ni par habitant du coup
pour terminer est ce que vous vous
confrère est ce que vous observez une
baisse ou alors une augmentation du
nombre de patients qui présentent des
symptômes du coït 19
non moi personnellement non mais les
collègues si ils sont perçus une légère
baisse sur les patients qui présentent
des différents symptômes de corps l'a
bien vu ce qu'ils sont extrêmement
variés merci beaucoup
nagasu sa vie d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin en iran